is it possible to systematically learn
how to escape restraints like handcuffs
rope zip ties the best at it or not the
military the Nazir program people they
are criminals I learn how to get out of
handcuffs from a 15 year old it was in
charge of meth sales and and uh
evolution in Tijuana is there a system
to it I mean it's not it specifically a
system it's uh usually what they what
happens is they'll buy a set of
handcuffs and they will mess around with
them in a playing feature so
one thing I do in a class is first off
I'm honest about the fact that some you
know all the restraints are temporary
even marriage
this is this is like wait can we just
pause on the Deep philosophical you're
like the immortal Musashi with that
statement all all restraints are
temporary even marriage uh I'll just uh
just I just like adding that one in
there for last because this is a dark
subject every cage can be escaped all
restraints are temporary you you either
free yourself from the restraints
somebody else takes them off or you die
and your body rots your way around them
you know those are the options
um and I like that first option myself
the second option is pretty cool if you
can convince somebody to do that for you
but that first option is an interesting
one
you have to deconstruct restraints not
all restraints are made the same uh you
can train to get out of handcuffs here
in the US and you know focus on the
Paris Smith and Western handcuffs which
are kind of the most common brand of
handcuffs here
but if you find yourself in detention
somewhere in Russia the handcuffs out
there are completely different you know
the key way is different the mechanism
is different but some of the same ways
of bypassing those mechanisms are at the
style so in Russia what kind are they
using to run they're gonna travel in
there I need this information I'll send
you a specific model and details on how
to get out of those uh but basically
asking for a friend I'm sorry so what I
do is I I take I take a pair of Smith
and Wesson handcuffs I put them in the
middle of uh of three people in the in a
class I spread them out and I have them
place them on each other in a just
playing manner I have Hank I have
handcuffed Keith there and I have a pair
of bolt cutters there in case somebody
gets stuck does something stupid so they
they play with each other as far as
putting them on randomly I show them how
to put them on appropriately and then I
show them a handcuff key and a handcuff
key will open up handcuffs interestingly
enough but the thing about a handcuff
key is it's not made to be used by the
person that is in those handcuffs
so that's the first lesson there
if you have a handcuff key handcuff keys
are the most used tool to open up
handcuffs in custody situations you know
both criminals escape from the police to
people escaping from criminals just a
standard hidden handcuff key so I show
them how to modify the Handcuff key so
it's more optimal to use on yourself
with just basic garbage that you can
find piece of wire a zip type piece
basically how to put a leverage arm on
the Handcuff key so you can actually
spin it in the keyway behind your back
or in front of you
trying to think I don't think I've ever
been in handcuffs uh appropriate way to
handcuff somebody's Palms out how much
restriction is there in terms of there's
a lot if it's a is it hinge handcuffed
there's a lot of restriction
can you reach back you could try and
reach back or you can basically put
yourself in a non-compromised position
and
feed the most of your palm meat into the
Handcuff way so when they shut it shut
it on you you have more space to work
with so you can spin your hand we call
it the passive resistance again you go
through a process within where you
deconstruct how people are handcuffed uh
handcuff keys and how to modify hand
cookie to be able to use on yourself and
these all of these things they're
constructing as we go so they basically
hey what's a grinding surface well
there's concrete outside so they grind
an angle on the key so you can get a key
not to go straight into the keyway but
you can get it into the key we had an
angle for example it's something it's
something that is out there as far as a
method
you can't spin a key behind your back
because it's small it's designed to be
used by somebody else opening those
handcuffs on you so you put an arm on it
so you can leverage our arms so you can
spin it behind your back
you learn how to put yourself in not a
compromised position if somebody asks
you for your hand cut your hands so they
could be cuffed you don't do this
you know you do that or you put yourself
in a cable grip behind your back which
is a pretty strong grip and it's hard to
spread those hands apart it's also
something that people go into
automatically when they're in fear so
all these things are advantageous for
you
and uh you learn how not only people get
restrained but you see videos of them
because I show a bunch of abduction
that's actually happening live
again the best thing is avoidance but
specifically when you work around
restraints is number one learn how some
of these restraints work
number two is learning how some of the
ready-made tools to get out of the
restraints look like function
and number three which is the advanced
level is learn how to construct all
these things yourself which is I think
that is the that is the best thing you
can show somebody for handcuffs I just
use a standard pair of handcuffs and
then we deconstruct other very
specialized handcuffs that might be out
there and you show them if you're going
to travel somewhere learn what
restraints are commonly in the available
in the environment somebody going to
North sub-Saharan Africa
carrying a plastic Hank of key is
that's going to be useless out there
because there's not going to be standard
handcuffs out there that would be
open with that type of key out there
you're probably going to be tied up with
a chain and a padlock of some sort maybe
a 40 millimeter Chinese padlock with a
plastic core that you can open with a
a lighter if you can burn the core melt
the core open or if you can leverage
that open that's a pretty easy thing to
open or a bobby pin you could reach all
the way in the back and open the latch
above rope
uh the common yeah it is common uh this
is one of my favorite things for rope
something I usually carry in some places
another gift for you if you want
it's a ceramic razor blade nice is it
capable of cutting
nice that small uh you can put it behind
a label I've seen some students put the
Levi's label on there and just sew it
back on
um it is non-magnetic non-ferrous so in
and out of uh you know that type of
situation you can get in and it's
something you can have with you
everywhere
this is a pretty fancy one or you can
just grab a simple razor blade actually
learning how to use or leverage a razor
blade between your palms and
know how to go up and down with it to be
able to cut yourself of course so that's
just practice to do that well it's
practice and it's also exposure to just
this is a possibility this is how you
can hide it again the whole smuggling
aspect comes from a criminal uh criminal
mindset type setting so how how things
are hidden where they're hidden and when
I talk about concealing objects of this
nature it usually comes from
smuggling you know the fact that I have
something in a notebook comes from
heroin smuggling
if you're not looking at the school of
criminality you're missing out on a big
part of the equation
so for people who want to learn about
this do you teach courses on this too
yeah you know what's the right what's
the wreck how do you get in touch with
you or learn from you do you have stuff
online or is it online so I have some
stuff on my patreon uh specifically I
have a patreon where I share a lot of
the
online material like basically a bunch
of this is my notebook I have a bunch of
stuff that I I just met somebody in
Philadelphia that showed me a pretty
unique way of utilizing a box cutter as
a weapon so I wrote some of that down I
filmed some of it
um and it's not for any other reason I'm
not trying to create dangerous people
out there it's like hey look at this
this is something that's out there right
um so a lot of that information some of
those notes and stuff like that I keep
on my patreon I used to share it openly
on Facebook and Instagram but that uh
that has not uh been possible anymore
well I'm a member your patreon and
recommend people signing up it's really
great because you also have philosophy
you're you're you're the you're the uh
the Mexican Miyamoto Musashi uh so it's
not just these skills it's also the
philosophy around it like I got that
that book of five rings before I went
into training like I took that with me
through training the whole aspect of you
know go to places uh frightening to the
common brand of men you know be put in
jail and extricate yourself with your
own wisdom I think he was speaking about
experiencing experience you know the
whole Warriors journey of the heroes
journey of going out there and actually
risking
um I think that's a pretty
big basis and aspect of what the work I
do and showing some of these things
there's a tendency to people say hey I'm
afraid to go to Mexico uh what do I need
to know like well if you're afraid to go
to Mexico to go to Mexico
um I mean I was in Detroit I was pretty
afraid when I was in Detroit in some
parts of Detroit and uh the South Side
Chicago
um but uh
I don't want to be dictated where I can
go and where I can't go because of
safety I want to take responsibility for
that myself and figure out ways of being
more capable and an asset to the people
around me and myself
and that comes from experience
um and people don't want to risk getting
a shoulder injury rolling in Jiu Jitsu
or don't want to risk getting a bloody
nose and boxing but that is the way